the first function we will look at in
this session is Y or f of X equal to the
absolute value of x how do we plot this
on the graph when x is 0 Y as well is 0
0 comma 0 will be one of the points if X
is 1 then Y as well will be 1 this point
is 1 comma 1 2 comma 2 will be another
point and what will y equal when X is
minus 1 the absolute value of minus 1 is
1 the absolute value just ignores the
sign of the number minus 1 comma 1 will
be another point and similarly minus 2
comma 2 will also be another point the
graph will look a bit like this this is
the graph of the absolute value of x
this graph also tells us that no matter
what the value of x is the absolute
value will always be non-negative it
lies entirely in the non negative region
of y let's try modifying this function a
bit what if the function is f of X is
equal to absolute value of x plus 1 will
you be able to draw a graph try it if x
is 0 then Y will be 0 plus 1 which is 1
0 comma 1 will be one of the points if X
is 1 then Y will be equal to 2 1 comma 2
and if X is 2 then Y is 3 and so on if X
is minus 1 then Y will be absolute value
of minus 1 plus 1 that will be 2 minus 1
comma 2 is the point we are talking
about and in the same way minus 2 comma
3 will be another point this is how the
graph will look like notice what
happened we added a constant to the
function and the graph moved up we added
1
the graph moved up one unit will the
graph move down if we subtract a
constant from the function look at the
next function and try plotting its graph
here we have subtracted a one from the
original function f of X is equal to the
absolute value of x if X is zero Y will
be minus one we mark the point zero
comma minus 1 if X is 1 then Y will be 0
1 comma 0 is another point 2 comma 1 and
so on now if x is minus 1 then y will be
1 minus 1 which equals 0 minus 1 comma 0
will be that point and similarly minus 2
comma 1 will be another joining the
points the graph will look like this
compared to the original we can see that
it has moved down a bit so what are the
conclusions we can draw if y is equal to
f of X is the original function and we
add a constant to it the graph will move
or shift up and if we subtract a
constant from it then the graph will
shift down this concept is very
important what if we add a constant to
the input something like Y is equal to f
of X plus 1 what will happen to the
graph let's see that on a new page we
know the graph of our original function
f of X is equal to the absolute value of
x what if the function is something like
Y is equal to absolute value of x plus 1
here we added one just to the input X if
X is zero then Y will be 1 if X is 1
then Y will be 2 if X is minus 1 then Y
will be 0 if X is minus 2 then Y will be
absolute value of minus 1
which is one so minus two comma one is
another point and minus three comma two
will be another joining the points the
graph would look like this
comparing it to the original graph this
one has shifted to the left by one unit
adding a constant to the input shifts
the graph towards the left and what if
we subtract a constant from the input
try drawing the graph for this function
when the value of x is zero then Y will
be the absolute value of minus 1 which
is 1 when X is 1 Y will be 0 when X is 2
then Y will be 1 3 comma 2 and minus 1
comma 2 would be a couple of more points
and drawing the graph we can see that it
has shifted towards the right conclusion
if we add a positive constant to the
input the graph will move towards the
left and if we subtract a positive
constant from the input the graph will
move towards the right all the four
concepts you learned in the session are
important these two as well as the
previous two if you haven't understood
this video well I suggest you watch it
again